katia coup de chaud cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale des activistes de
l'organisation écologiste extinction
rébellion se sont enchaînés aux grilles
de l'assemblée nationale oui absolument
une action totalement inattendue aux
militantes sont actuellement enchaînée
par le cou donc l'action n'est pas du
tout terminé
elles ont laissé des clés envoyait des
clés à des ministres et des députés qui
ne sont quasiment pas venu à part les
députés insoumis qui les ont soutenus
caroline fiables à des soumises
amène participé à l'action en
s'enchaînant aux seuls avec certains
militants alors les militantes qui sont
actuellement enchaîné risquer la
disqueuse mais finalement il ya eu une
entente avec le directeur de cabinet du
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand elles resteront jusqu'à
la fin du vote sans être délogés avec
l'année autour du cou si les par les
forces de police alors en tout cas je
vous propose d'écouter de revenir sur
cette action avec camille etienne
militante écologiste
ça me rend triste parce que parce que
c'était beau en fait ce qui se passait
c'est dire que c'était c'était pour moi
ce que ça a permis s'est montré que
quand on sait on n'a pas d'autre choix
que de demander des actions radicales
radical dans ce sens qui va à la racine
du problème
y'avait pas du tout des militants dans
cette convention y avait des gens qui
ressort y avait même des
climato-sceptiques et qui s'appelle
olivier quai des climato-sceptiques et
face à l'urgence face aux scientifiques
qui sont venu leur expliquer à quel
point c'était urgent ils en sont sortis
avec des mesures qui vont qui sont
radicales concrètement donc ça pour moi
c'était beau et le fait que le
gouvernement piétine comme ça dessus sur
que la parole un président de la
république qui est pas capable de tenir
sa parole compte les yeux dans les yeux
des citoyens est dit promis je faire
passer ça sans filtre et qu'après il
revient dessus complètement mais c'est
flippant en fait on sent pas du tout en
démocratie et moi ça me fait pas
vraiment on va parler du texte qui va
être votée dans très peu de temps il est
inspiré par les 146 propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat il
reste 69 mesure après le passage des
parlementaires qui les ont amenuisé
vidés de leur sens de la vie des
personnes qui ont participé à cette
convention de la vie
évidemment des écologistes des mesures
dont peu ambitieuse sur les transports
l'aménagement du territoire
l'alimentation le logement
matthieu orphelin par exemple qui a
quitté lrm ce député a accusé le tijd
avoir 15 ans de retard les insoumises
voteront pas le texte vous proposait
d'écouter alexis corbière des
semi on va voter contre
voilà avec une insuffisance évidemment
la critique ont apporté pendant tous les
débats
vous avez entendu nos critiques dans ce
cas d' intéressant aussi c'est là on en
revient un peu à la discussion un peu à
l'histoire c'est même les expériences
soi-disant de consultation démocratique
les expériences nouvelles des citoyens
tirés au sort qui pouvait être
intéressant mais passer au tamis du
maquereau nisme finissent dans une
entourloupe et même ceux qui avaient
participé et il y avait des discussions
tout à fait intéressante à ceux des à ce
débat cette convention climat se
retrouve aujourd'hui fort en colère et
floué par ce texte qui est un texte
d'affichage politique et d'insuffisance
façon on l'a fait entendre pendant les
débats et tout à l'heure on votera
contre cette loi tout en invitant les
citoyens à être présent dans le débat
politique qui s'ouvre est la vraie
transition écologique si nous arrivons
au pouvoir elle aura lieu en 2022 mais
ya rien à attendre de cette majorité
lors du côté des républicains celle
inverse il estime que les taxes et
emprunts d' écologie punitive de
taxation ils vont publier une contre
proposition
en tout cas pour avoir une vision tout à
fait objectif du texte un son ambition
était d'aider à réduire les gaz à effet
de serre et bien il ne va pas y parvenir
qui le dit et bien tout simplement le
ministère de la transition écologique
merci katia technique en direct donc de
l'assemblée nationale à paris